now let's dig in more specifically to
Goldman Sachs I've spoken about this in
pieces before I want to dedicate a
little bit of time to it Goldman Sachs
Donald Trump ran against Hillary
Clinton's perceived coziness with Wall
Street that very acutely included
investment bank Goldman Sachs Trump
slammed Hillary Clinton the entire
campaign during debates even for her
connections to Goldman Sachs he slammed
Hillary Clinton for giving speeches to
Goldman Sachs and now Trump is hiring
the people who hired Hillary Clinton to
give those speeches you'll remember that
it wasn't just through the Hillary
Clinton insults that Trump slammed
Goldman Sachs Trump also slammed Goldman
Sachs during the Republican primary
criticizing Ted Cruz for having taken a
loan from Goldman Sachs saying I know
the guys at Goldman Sachs they have
total total control over Cruz just like
they have total control over Hillary
Clinton Wow really sharp pointed
critiques and it seemed almost like it
was going both ways because you'll
remember that in September Goldman Sachs
banned certain employees from donating
to Donald Trump's campaign it seemed
official Trump is anti Goldman Goldman
doesn't want employees at a certain
level donating to Donald Trump period
and then we had Trump's final pitch to
voters Trump actually used an image of
Lloyd Blankfein in a TV ad to argue that
insiders from Wall Street had ruined the
lives of ordinary Americans to enrich
themselves Wow very Bernie Sanders like
very populist sounding except now the
Trump swamp is being filled with Goldman
Sachs veterans we have Goldman Sachs's
Gary Cohn who is going to be heading up
Trump's Economic Council
we have Goldman Sachs's Steve minuchin
who is going to be heading out heading
up trumps secretary Department and then
of course we have climate science denier
Anthony scaramouche
who is a former Goldman Sachs guy and a
key transition member for Trump
what is more globalist than Goldman
Sachs of course globalism that Trump and
his cohorts like Alex Jones and other
conspiracy theorists deplored and then
we have Wilbur Ross who will be Donald
Trump's Commerce Secretary worth nearly
three billion dollars and while not as
closely connected to Goldman Sachs made
a ton of money with the exact same types
of activities that Trump absolutely
slammed during the campaign oh and Steve
Bannon former goldman sachs banker now
there's always a defense from the
trumpets and from trump and usually
those defenses require the suspension of
disbelief now the new party line is
according to the all rightists and the
trumpets it's oh these people that trump
is hiring that he used to say we're
really bad they're smart businessmen and
when you bring in people who are not the
political status quo you're going to
have people that maybe have done some
things as really astute and smart shrewd
business people that some of us might
not like but they're going to be part of
making America great again the swamp is
not being drained
ladies and gentlemen repeal Obamacare
it's a disaster actually many of those
provisions are good flip flop prosecute
and jail Hillary Clinton net flip-flop
that was just something for the campaign
don't care about that now make America
great again because Hillary was the
Goldman Sachs candidate multiple Goldman
Sachs people brought on to Trump's
administration you've been bamboozled
Trump supporters I hate to break it to
you join us on Facebook give us a like
facebook.com slash David Pakman show
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I liked the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like $300 for prescription
glasses hi which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing